good morning John and all the rest of
you I come to you now from this familiar
vestibule with advice for the graduates
of college and high school a familiar
format the well-meaning nice tool who'll
grant you this an afternoon save for
cash or a favor food with no flavor
inspiring advice for the next few days
you'll do well have some as kool-aid
it's time you must bite of the cherry of
life it'll taste like fear and hope and
Diet Coke and rainbows don't be
surprised when the pain grows cuz this
kind of gonna suck but you can't abstain
now there is no do not there's no F and
try there's no I don't wanna if you
don't like it than die well now I'm not
condoning the suicide I'm just trying to
be motivation a little overly sensation
I'll get it I'm sure so I'm sure oh you
don't know what abjure means maybe
you're not as prepared as you seems like
rejecting an error but with like a bit
extra care I'm pretty sure they should
have taught you that I'm making a point
here and it's that you don't know jack
best of you can hope to have been taught
to learn to yearn for more that you'll
still have to earn cuz you're not ending
learning you're ending this one
structure and yeah I'm starting to sound
like a schmuck sure but you gotta have
to keep learning one way or the other
whether it's how to make change or be
someones mother or make music or coffee
or toffee or spreadsheets or hotels or
laws or websites or bed sheets don't you
dare think but I majored in it I won't
do that
well I majored in chemistry what did I
do with it make videos for nerds I'm an
entrepreneur I taught myself 90% of what
I've learned and that's normal it's
boring it's average but it's true and
for most of you hearing this it'll be
true for you too and it should be if
it's not a night life's hardly real and
it's scary sure be wary but deal
insecurity is something that you're
always going to feel so the deep dark
yawning pit of the next step of your
life might look like a fall but it could
be a flight and who knows that pit might
be filled with ice cream and you might
be lactose intolerant but you give what
I mean
or maybe pain failure is all the to
eating you I'm just baiting you whether
you're facing hell or a festival my
point here right now is grab it by the
testicle make it your [ __ ] this is all
that you've got it's your one shot it's
short it's actually probably not while
you grab life by the balls be careful
with people don't be a creeper you might
find a deep hole success might be
however you define it but if you define
it wrong you're never gonna find it or
even if you do it'll suck to know that
you got there at the expense of those
who you love or would have if you'd ever
even tried cuz it's not he who has the
most toys when he died it's just life
and if you're not at least trying to be
happy
even why the one you don't know jack to
be nice to others whether you become
executives or baristas or stay-at-home
mothers and finally have fun okay that's
all I think I'm done that was a pretty
good day in Amman so I'll see you on
Wednesday John